[موسيقى]
بين الاف الاسواق المعروفه تاريخيا باتت
المتاجر الالكترونيه الاكثر ارتيادا فهي
تقدم منتجات عمليه وتمنح زائرها صفه لا
زمان ولا مكان صوره لمشهد جديد لم يكن
كذلك قبل عده عقود هي رحله طويله انتهت
بجعل التطبيقات الالكترونيه جزءا من روتين
الحياه وليست مجرده وسائل ترفيه او عمل
فكيف حدث ذلك
في صيف عام
1983 عقد في مدينه اسبانيا الامريكيه
مؤتمر دولي لمصممي تكنولوجيا كان موضوعه
المستقبل لن يكون كما كان عليه في السابق
من بين الحضور وقف شاب يرتدي ربطه عنق
صغيره وقميصا ابيض قام بثني اكمامه القى
هذا الشاب خطابا حماسيا وكان يلوح بذراعيه
بين الفينه والاخرى تحدث بثقاع عن رؤيته
للحواسيب المستقبليه وقال انه عندما تكون
لدينا اجهزه كمبيوتر محموله مزوده بوصلات
لاسلكيه يمكن ان يتجول الناس في اي مكان
ويلتقطون بريدهم الالكتروني قال الشاب ان
الجهاز الموعود سيحوي مثل متجر تسجيلات
حيث سيتم تنزيل البرامج عبر خطوط الهاتف
كان هذا المتحدث هو
المؤسس شركه ابل الامريكيه بعد سته اشهر
من اطلاقه اول جهاز ماكنتوش في العام
التالي شهد العالم ولاده اول حاسوب جيب
عملي وكان ذلك بامضاء من شركه
كان المنظم الاول الذي تم اطلاقه في عام
والمنظم الثاني الذي تم اطلاقه في عام
1986 لهما غطاء منزلق من البلاستيك الصلب
المميز وبلوحه مفاتيح بحجم 6 في 6 تضم
احرفا مرتبه ابجديا ضم هذا الحاسوب
المحمول اله حاسبه وساعه وتطبيقات اخرى
مالوفه
في عام
1993 قدمت شركه اي بي ام اول هاتف ذكي في
العالم وكان مشابها لحاسوب سعيون حيث تم
تجهيزه بتطبيقات مماثله في عام
1997 تضمن نوكيا 610 اصدارا مدمجا من لعبه
لافعى تتحرك لتاكل مجموعه من النقاط في
طريقها واعتبرت هذه اللعبه اول تطبيق
للهاتف المحمول كذلك جاء جهاز الايبود
الاول ايضا مع العاب مدمجه مثل
بريكير انتظر العالم حتى دخول الالفيه
الثانيه ليشهد القفزه التاليه في
تكنولوجيا التطبيقات التي اعلنت مع اطلاق
الهاتف الذكي
في عام 2002 ضم هذا الجهاز امكانيه ارسال
البريد الالكتروني عبر الهاتف وخواصه
دردشه الاخرى قبل ان تعلن شركه ابل في عام
2010 عن متجر التطبيقات الشهير الذي تم
اطلاقه بعد عام
ظهر في عام 2014 تحول في استخدام
التطبيقات من الالعاب الممتعه ووسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي الى انماط الحياه
باكملها فدخل في التجاره والاعلام
والثقافه والجغرافيا وغيرها في العام 2020
توفر نحو مليونين وتسعه الاف تطبيقا
للهواتف المحموله في متجر تطبيقات ابل
بينما يحتوي متجر اندرويد بلاي على ثلاثه
ملايين واربعه عشر الف تطبيق
مع تواصل التطويرات على اجهزه الهواتف
المحموله ومتصفحات الويب الوظيفيه توسع
انتشار التطبيقات الالكترونيه يوما بعد
يوم حتى انها اصبحت جزءا من الحياه
اليوميه للكثيرين حول العالم
[موسيقى]